This video is so dense. I just peed in my basement. If you want
to watch a streamer that wants to pee in the potty, go watch
someone else. Oh, you look tired. You bang another dude tonight?
Oh, sweet. And then like my heart's breaking, you know? That's
actually really psycho to try to have kids, not be able to have
them, and then mock other people for not having kids? Bro, bring
your wife's big old and bring her over to our house. Who told
them this was a good strategy?
>> So, I think I believe Brittany Venti dropped a full
piece on The Quartering drama. The Quartering drama from start
to finish, which I believe will include some DMs. We also have
the DMs from The Quartering crashing out last night. He got into
a fight with Side Scrollers. Let's go.
The chronicles of a cry bully, The Quartering. Big video from
Brittany Venti, apparently very well researched.
Should be pretty good. And we haven't even covered any of The
Quartering stuff, so it's it's going to be good. I know it's
going to be good. I feel it.
Let me tell you this about Venti. I would I would I would give
everything I had to have babies with that girl. Even even
why?
Why would you say the what the
Like okay, I get it. Like sometimes you say like that, you're
like drunk or something. Maybe you say that but dude, about somebody
you like essentially your colleagues with? That uh feels weird.
And he's also married and bro. Bro!
I would I would give
everything I had to have babies with that girl. Even even though
the all my kids look like sharks, I'm in. Quote more about
Why did you got to throw that one in, dude? Holy [__]
Why would you Now, he means sharks as in like hammerheads.
But like there's obviously a slur that goes along with that that
is like invert like it's weird, okay? Was this from The Quartering
IRL stream? Cool. I did this together from a Quartering IRL stream.
His goal was to actually stalk women. At one point he follows
a woman with children whilst making remarks. She looks back in
fear several times. For several minutes. What the [__]
Share this. No way. >> If I did see a girl in a chainmail
bikini, you know
we would uh Dude, what are you Bro, this guy really went IRL
with this hairline and no hat? Just put a hat on,
Put a hat on, dog.
That's a that's a disastrous hairline to take this like a video
from this
What what's happening? Uh and we would have got her on camera.
Here. Here's some milf. Dude. Dude, ain't no way. Ain't no This
guy is sick. This guy is
Dude, look how close she is when he says this. Here. Here's some
milf.
And we got
we got the girl that boys
Why? Why why in the world would you do this? Why did you do this?
Why did you do
Here's another one. Here's another one.
Oh, here's another one. Oh, you're so close to these women when
you're saying this. You're
This is in Bristol, Wisconsin. Oh, sure couple overflow. She's
a little bit old, but she overflow.
That's what I'm talking about. Milf, yeah. Yeah. She's keeping
it tight. You know she DTF. She got Dude. Dude, I didn't hear
that comment. You know she DTF if she got kids. Bro, did this
guy just not Did this guy just not get Bro, I Dude, she I do
feel like she definitely heard that. Hold on. I couldn't tell
cuz it's like kind of pixelated. I feel like
I feel like she was turning to make sure he was going further
away or something.
Hi, dude. Here you go.
Uh excuse me, officer.
Uh I know it looks bad, but somebody paid me $20 to do it.
Okay, we're back to the Brittany Venti video of more disgusting
comments from this weirdo. Even even though the all my kids look
like sharks, I'm in. Quote more about Brittany Venti. Nobody
gives a [__] about that dumb I'm just trying to be
nice to everybody. This gets me in trouble online, apparently.
And those same dumbass women
uh turn around and pretend like they weren't begging you for
help and then try to paint you as some sort of creeper. I definitely
want to have with Oh. [snorts]
Where have I heard this rhetoric before?
What's going on? Stupid. I built these stupid careers and now
they're all turning on me. Brittany from The Venting here. The
Quartering has gone woke and everyone's channels are under attack.
There's a lot of scandals and Hi, dude. I I hold on.
She got
>> She had like the Megamind
effect on here and her eyes are the same distance apart. are
under attack. There's a lot of scandals and controversy with
this including deplatforming, the Wisconsin Bull, alcoholism,
blackout streams, begging his audience for money when he's a
multimillionaire,
being a simp trying to get a crumb of coochie from every attractive
woman in a any mile radius. By the way, Lauren Southern's sister
is also super hot. Lauren Southern or Tomi Lahren? Lauren Southern,
that's easy. I'll take [clears throat] a girl with some hips.
She got some hips. Tomi Fine, I might
I personal interactions with Lauren Southern, she's been wildly
manipulative. And Lauren Southern, much like many of the other
female conservatives, I thought was a friend of mine only to
find out later that they had a secondary DM group where they
would talk garbage about me all the time. And pathetic. She told
me she was destitute, too. She told me she Wait, what? Okay,
so many things happened at the same time there. One, the story
is crazy. But I was trying to look at this. I thought Lauren
Southern had finally dropped our tape as revenge. I've been trying
to get people to believe me for years. Disappointed. I thought
was a friend of mine only to find out later that they had a secondary
DM group where they about me all the time. And pathetic. She
told me she was destitute, too. She told me she had no money.
Then told me the offer I gave her, which was more than generous,
wasn't enough money. I've noticed that this is a repeated pattern
of Bro, everybody everybody was looking to pull Lauren Southern
into their
This woman Bro, I
I don't even know how to describe it. Tim Pool wanted to hire
Lauren. The Quartering wanted to hire Lauren. Everybody wanted
to hire Lauren.
And then she went I believe she went to Ten of that point, right?
That would be around that time. >> behavior. Jeremy goes
to simple woman. He expects something out of it for being a nice
guy. And then when it doesn't work out, he becomes a sour simp.
To have white Skullcandy headphones. I think they're so cool.
And I finally bought myself some and I was like, this is going
to I this is nice. This is nice. I'm upgrading. Yeah, well you
could probably put it on your WikiFeet or whatever at Amazon
wish list or something. You're on WikiFeet. Did you know that?
I I usually peruse
There's no Look at her face.
No way. No way. No way her face changes like that. No way.
Yeah, well you could probably put it on your WikiFeet
or whatever
at Amazon
Dude, I There's no way it can't be disingenuously edited, right?
Dude, she list or something. You're on WikiFeet. Did you know
that? I I usually peruse the comments.
Huh, this video is so dense.
Holy [__] I feel like I have to stop
Dude, it's so dense.
Not cool, Sydney Watson. She talked
What? I usually peruse the comments.
Bro, who in the world says like this? Yeah, there's this fetish
website you're on. I read the comments sometimes. >> She
talked massive amounts of [__] about me in these
feminist DM groups after I paid for everything with the publico.
It made me want to sue her. She never paid a single penny for
anything at that company. I lost $100,000 or Jeremy confirmed
doormat. Yeah. Yeah. He throws money
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> expecting something a little
more out of them while claiming that they're his friends. You
don't really make intimate romantically charged comments to your
female friends, especially not when you're married. And a conservative.
Jeremy Handley from The Quartering got famous because he spammed
the YouTube algorithm enough times with his milktoast content.
And any competition he would have had got banned off of the platform.
He was an anti-cancel culture, anti-woke, free speech advocate
up until now where he has successfully utilized his influence
of 2 million subscribers
and Oh, Shima making it big again. Let's
You contacted Eddie from Kick after publicly talking about taking
Kino Casino's channel down and told Josh Moon that you were going
to take him out with your connections.
Oh. This is So, I don't know if I went through any of the tweets
from The Quartering on stream. I had them in an old docket. But
yes, The Quartering targeted the YouTube channels apparently
of PPP and Andy Warski, the the Kino Casino channels, their clipping
channels. And which which weird is they got taken down and I
thought it was like a ban evasion thing, but Andy Warski got
unbanned like years ago from YouTube. He was not banned on YouTube.
They rebanned him somehow.
But I I also I have no idea how this happened cuz it seems like
they didn't even get notices. They were just gone. They just
Warski said his channel just like evaporated. Just got Thanos
snapped out of existence. >> quote non-Indian YouTube representative
to get the Kino Casino banned. And the reason he felt that it
was okay to do this? Harassment of his wife, aka
>> No no beef with you, bro, outside of a little bro thing
you did bro Uh by flagging down videos bro on YouTube bro because
they made fun of you bro. That's pretty soft bro. That's softer
than like baby dude bro. >> Kino Casino is a comedy channel.
They live stream on Kick and they had a YouTube channel. And
one of their segments was to make fun of Jeremy because of his
constant need to overshare. He has a long history of oversharing
most infamously for his bowels being under attack.
The [laughter] pooth is out there pal. I have a anxiety diarrhea.
HE HAS ANXIETY DIARRHEA. I HAD LIKE
a diarrhea moment and I was I I was like oh my god, I have to
go. The Dude, why
Bro, why
He tries to [__] these women too. Why would you do
that after saying these things with them around?
Like he I I he's made several passes it seem seemingly in public
with these women and
how can he do that after after having these moments on stream?
>> men's room and there was all over the place. All over
the toilet, all like you know, it was overflowing out of the
toilet. It was on the back wall of the toilet. Well,
>> the garbage can. This turns into people
tracking the literal trail of destruction he left behind. >> So
he's
>> That's crazy to go and pull this up pull up paint and
start
charting a course. So then he
he realizes he can't go in the stall and so he jumps back out
and finds the nearest >> trail of smears
all the way from the shoe section to the electronics department.
We're leaving a trail. Yeah, there was a little bit. There was
a little bit on the ground where I because nobody goes shopping
for shoes at Walmart. WHAT? I I LIKE NO, he's funny. [laughter]
He's going to [__] in the shoe box. Funny, not a
shoe
What? What?
I'm I'm consistently just saying to myself why in the world is
this being
I hit the back wall.
>> I hit the back wall. another detour. SO THEN THIS GUY'S
NOW DRAWING IT in real time. There is a little bit of [__]
that's going down Jeremy's leg and hitting the floor.
I I'm on the home stretch. With each step a little more is coming
out.
Unfortunately, Jeremy could not make the bathroom in time leaving
his usual racing stripes in his underwear. You know, women probably
never had to clean pee off the toilet seat before they live with
a man. Women probably never had to
um wash racing stripes out of underwear before living with men.
It's really no wonder why
Dude, I don't know. I There There needs to be more words. I don't
have the words. What in the world is this guy saying in public?
How did this guy not get How did this guy not get exploded before
this? For all the insanely cringe he says. What is going on?
What is going
I Dude, I don't have the words. It's >> Like he's in a
committed relationship with his bidet. When I travel now, the
bidet is a thing I miss.
I mean, I'll just say it. I miss it more than I miss my wife
and I miss MY DOG.
>> NO, NO, NO. For 200 grand a year, I'm going barehanded
picking up each turd pile. I don't even care. >> And poor
Jeremy just doesn't seem to understand why we make fun of it
even though he's openly sharing it as if that magically makes
it less gross. Nope,
Walmart janitor. I hope the comment was worth it. But no, no
panic diarrhea. I guess I'm not allowed to share stories because
if I share a story, it gets turned around against me like I like
even though I willingly
Dude, I It's like watching Shoe Be Reviews again. Dude, how are
so many people like this? And like old YouTubers who've watched
this happen to so many
Bro, what embarrassing stories Bro, I'm
I'm never I'm never telling another personal story again. I thought
I was I thought I was like
I thought it was okay when I told the shoplifting thing.
I I Dude, even that's too far. That's way too far to tell that
personal story. There's no way. Man, that's already That's treading
dangerous ground. I'm never doing it again. Holy You guys don't
get to know anything about me never again. >> Welcome to
the internet, Jeremy. >> Poor Jer Bear can't overshare
anymore. You do still have a YouTube channel to overshare on,
don't you, Jer Bear? He acts like he's okay with people making
fun of him and he's said this over and over, but clearly he isn't
if now he can't overshare. He immediately tries to deplatform
people for making fun of him because his wife is off the table.
She's not an internet person. >> spent much time thinking
about how to best handle the issues with harassment and cyberbullying
and magic. My wife has long been a victim of these actions.
>> No evidence of that, of course. His
Dude, the the like puffing your hair up in the front to deal
with going bald. I don't
Who told him this was a good strategy? Right? Like where his
hairline's receding, he just like puffs it up. He like tries
to thicken it up or something and then he just puffs it up. Who
told him that to do this? Who told him this looks good? >> wife
is a nobody. No one would know who she is if she wasn't married
to him. So I find that extraordinarily HARD TO
>> AND HE'S LIKE I'M BEING HARASSED and my Dude, I
When I reacted to Hutch, Hutch was like this guy is so amped.
He's like going crazy. It's like man, I'm just I'm trying to
get within the same I'm getting trying to get within 100 light
years of PPP. That's where I'm trying to get. That's my goal.
I want to be like 10% of the energy of PPP, okay? That's That's
where I'm trying to get. And so I'm like that Hutch was like
this guy is so amped. I'm like dude, I'm not even close. I'm
not even there yet. I'm trying to get there, okay? Listen, PPP's
in Canada. Maybe he can hook me up with whoever his coke dealer
is. But if he's on if he's just sober he's sober-minded he's
doing this, that's insane. Cuz I I literally try and I can't
get there. It's a talent, man. >> wife is getting these
phone calls and these packages IN THE MAIL. DEATH THREATS.
Provide some proof.
PPP is like absolutely that guy that he she's like you might
even think he's like a bad person sometimes, but when you go
out drinking it's like invite that guy. That guy's going to tell
a story and we're all going to lose our laughing. He's like the
guy he's the story guy in the group. You know what I mean? And
it's like yeah, he's an but man, he's a funniest in the world.
Is that Jussie
There's no proof of any OF THIS AND BY THE WAY
Jussie Smollett. Even if there was, we have nothing to do with
that. He's using his wife as a human shield to silence criticism.
During all of this cry bullying he did talking about how they're
harassing his wife for making jokes on details that he elected
to share on stream about his own life. You would think with someone
saying that their wife is a non-internet person that they wouldn't
go and post her on their community tab after crying about harassment.
But not only that, Jeremy Ham Bully here decided to actually
call his wife to come on stream to try to get more donations
utilizing her body. Once she comes down, I'm going to let her
off the hook quick. She I'm just have her do the job. Uh Dude,
Rakita's is obviously before Rakita's intervention. This is before
the court cases with his kids. Rakita is interplanetary right
now. He is somewhere out in the universe. He's on a spirit walk,
okay? He is astral projecting somewhere else. His His soul is
not with us, okay?
Yep, but only if you ordered can you look. And then um I'll read
every single super chat. Dude, this maybe it's not that bad.
going on? I'll read every single and I'll read every single super
chat and
I'm going to go back five seconds. I don't know what's going
on with my We keep going. Hi. Funny how he's not very protective
of his wife when it comes to her dignity. There's a guy at work
who claimed that vegan veg didn't smell. Well, I can tell you
this. My wife has been a vegetarian
Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude. You don't just get to make someone
part of your content and mention >> Okay, hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. I will say I will say that at least that's like
vaguely a compliment.
At least there's like some way you could possibly defend that
to your wife. You shouldn't say it. That's gross. That is gross.
But I thought he was going to say my wife's a vegetarian now
and she still her stank or something. I thought that's what he
was going to say. I'm like bro, you can't
That's where the bar is for this guy in my head. I thought he
was going to say the worst possible thing. He just said like
the second or third worst most most bad possible thing, okay?
>> constantly. You know, suddenly declare actually she's
a private person when it's convenient. >> more or less
attracted to me right now than you were 10 minutes ago? >> you
really want to know the answer to And the most interesting part
here is that apparently she put him up to this whole thing of
getting them deplatformed. He says it here in the message himself.
But also my wife is not an internet person. Absolutely guilty
of
Let's talk about the mythos of the Wisconsin Bull.
Jeremy has a friend a long-term friend that he often mentions
by first name on his own stream and it turns out that this guy
who publicly had his full name on Twitter as his username with
his profile picture of himself. People found his Reddit account
and figured out that he frequents
subreddits. Him and his wife proactively
I've heard about this. I've heard tell of the bull, okay? I've
heard tell of this. I've been following
Yes. And not not is in this guy is the okay? Not that kind of
And Jeremy brings him around him and his wife. Um and bro, bring
your wife's big old and bring her over to our house.
It's 9:20. I think you could be to my house by by 10.
Uh I want to see your wife's big old set my house in the hot
tub. Hot tub
guy I'm s- I don't Guy, what are you doing? Guy, what are you
What are you doing here, guy? What is going on? Dude, this guy
is the um Oh.
This guy is the steel toe of the relationship, right? The Quartering
is clearly the steel toe here. Who's like eventually he thinks
he wants this and eventually it's going to be his wife and that
other guy's wife in a threesome with that guy with him in the
other room streaming or some [__] I feel like that's
the situation we're looking at right now. Upon discovering this
Wisconsin Bull, people found out that he also had a DV record,
a very long criminal record. And Jeremy's over here inviting
this guy over and the Wisconsin Bull's wife comes over to Jeremy's
house to clean, which is odd because from looking through his
stuff, he seems pretty wealthy. Shout out to his wife. She is
uh here
helping keep our house clean. But we're the crazy ones for talking
about his open marriage. That's why people start talking about
the Bull. He claims in his stance with Josh Moon that he totally
didn't know about this guy swinging, which is contradicted later
on that week where Jeremy goes on stream and says he's going
to play darts with him next week. Our world, the abyss, and reality
itself will unravel.
You must restore >> Is Adam coming over today? No, we have
darts probably next week. But meanwhile in Josh Moon's DMs, it's
him calling him the fairy word and he didn't know about this
degeneracy.
He said he converted to Christianity after Charlie Kirk's death.
And yet he continues to live this lifestyle. And not only that,
but if you look at his thumbnails, he often features very
Okay, hold on. Hold on. We should go back and read the actual
Josh Moon DMs. Give me a second.
Okay. I literally don't care that they make fun of me. Like her
family has seen unofficial truce. They delete the videos attacking
our marriage. I never mention them again. The more they do it,
the more I want to flex my connections to bury them. This is
the a one-time offer. They can meme on anyone else they want.
I don't care if they meme on my friend who apparently has a questionable
past, but this is an exploding offer. If they want to go to war,
I will win. I assume all these messages will be public, but I
like Andy. Just get rid of the videos claiming I let some f-
my wife and they continue to make 10k a month on YouTube and
I move on. But the dude, this You You literally can't win.
I feel like
I feel like you might have had a shot.
If you got If you were humble
and you went to PPP, I don't think so. I think like 99% chance
this doesn't work, but it's the only way it would work is if
you go to PPP, not Warski cuz let's be honest,
it's not like a It's not like an A&B type situation. It's
like a Pinky and the Brain type situation,
And you say, "Hey man, this is really with like my wife. I just
I Listen, I'm not going to do anything, but if you could like
help and just maybe not go harder, I would appreciate it, right?"
You basically get them to stop. I don't think you say take videos
down. That's the only chance you had here. The second you do
a threat through anybody else, you're [__] and they'll
go to war immediately cuz you've You've literally given them
all of the ammo they need to go to war with you, right? And they'll
win and they'll make tons of money off of you. This is the most
ill-considered, ill-conceived plan I've ever seen in my entire
life. He must have been blackout drunk sending these
Although there's no mistyping. I believe that's his excuse later
is that he's blackout drunk sending these DMs. >> It's
him calling him the fairy word and he didn't know about this
degeneracy.
He said he converted to Christianity after Charlie Kirk's death.
And yet he continues to live this lifestyle. And not only that,
but if you look at his thumbnails, he often features very
intimately provocative thumbnails. And even after this, the Bull
still had his own special role in Jeremy's discord. The one doing
the most damage to Jeremy's marriage is himself.
And maybe the Wisconsin Bull as well. And that's not the only
instance of this weird open marriage kind of thing that he pretends
to not have. He talks about how he doesn't get too personal with
his female employees. >> As a general rule, I don't try
to get too personal with my female employees or cohorts.
I don't ask them a lot of questions like that, you know. Oh,
no. We've We've covered this stuff from him. Dude, the receipts
on this one are going to be rough.
These are going to These are going to be tough, man. >> That's
how you stay out of trouble and you stay and you stay, you know,
keep everybody feeling comfortable and >> But then proceeds
to talk about his
Okay, nice touch right there. >> It's to talk about proceeds
keep everybody feeling comfortable
Humpter Bull?
Humpter Bull with the horns? Let's go. And then proceeds to talk
about his co-host Melanie Mac's breasts. Appreciate the touch.
Um if you're in the chat worried about where Melanie Mac is,
stop being such a loser. You guys all know I'm a anyway. I like
I like my I like my you know, two scoops full. And his co-host
is What is he doing?
I Dude, I
What is wrong with this guy? >> is a now married and has
been a Christian woman for quite some time now. Hold on, Coजर.
I don't Was PPP banned from YouTube cuz Warski was not banned.
Warski was unbanned. So they weren't They were not badmouthing
unless PPP was banned from YouTube somehow. Well, but just a
disclaimer, she says that she's okay with this, but I just wanted
to point this out that he's very hypocritical and is constantly
lying, especially about not getting Your clock stuck? Oh, maybe.
I didn't hit play on it. Okay, I'll take
We'll do like this. Yeah, like that. Okay, we should be good.
>> personal with women. I like hot take, there are exceptions,
but I also don't think men and women should be hanging out as
friends that often. You know, >> I agree unless they're
both like single, but if so if they're like in relationships,
married When I used to work in the office, they'd be like work
I never I was like, "Nah, dude, like that's weird. That's weird."
>> I did try some woman's breast milk at work and apparently
What is it?
What did the Is this guy talking about? off my wife and I didn't
know it was going to be a big deal. Oh, weird. I can understand
why that would make her upset. I would
I would have been upset, too.
>> Did The Quartering work at Blizzard?
I'd never heard Why would you ever Hold
Is he saying he tried it without her permission? I did try some
woman's breast milk at work and apparently it really pissed off
my wife and I didn't know it was going to be A BIG DEAL.
OH.
HIS WIFE. >> understand why that would make her
I would have been upset, too.
I thought he was saying he took the the breast milk without the
woman's
for a second and then like she was really I thought I thought
Melanie Mac would be like, "I understand why that would make
her mad."
>> And then like >> Also, why did she offer it to
you? Was this the one that was like, "You're my work husband"?
>> Yes, that's who it was.
Oh, that is worse. That is worse. That is worse.
He's like so against work wives, but then he'll drink their breast
milk when they call him their work husband. And not only that,
he's now telling his female co-workers about this. Totally inappropriate.
And that's not
I It's crazy. He's one of these people who just doesn't understand
that the story he's telling, the thing he's doing is just so
off-putting to the people around him. He just doesn't get it.
N- zero He just doesn't connect. >> he's done that, obviously
you guys saw the clips at the start of the video. Let me tell
you this about Venti. I don't know much as the host do either.
I would give it everything I had to have babies with that girl.
>> Then when I called him out on trying to deplatform the
Kino Casino, his tune changed. I really think you guys can do
it. If you spend like
If you double the amount of time you're spending on my stream
being mad, I think Brittany might actually see it and she might
let you touch a boob. He's pretending like he never simped for
me. He's a sour simp. >> Don't know what >> Cope
more about Brittany Venti. Nobody gives a [__] about
that dumb [__] Are you joking? You guys do because
she's hit She's about 40 and she's still single and childless.
>> It turns out he's the one with fertility issues considering
his search history.
Do you schedule a RMC semen analysis with or who? Who do you
schedule a RMC semen analysis with? He also says that he was
trying for a family with his wife and they still don't have kids.
Trying to start a family.
Um I've been feeling really, really, really stressed. And it's
fine that they couldn't have children, but I think his comments
are a little bit insensitive to his wife, aren't they? So this
whole thing is just a projection. Down to the part where he talks
about
Wait, does he not have kids? There's no way this guy does not
have
There's no way this guy has no kids.
Why is he calling people out for being barren? Why is he calling
Dude, what?
about my cat and using the litter box. Hopefully she can get
enough money to pay somebody to clean her cat's litter boxes
and maybe think about marrying her. Maybe one of you guys could
do it. >> Meanwhile, he can't even make the toilet himself.
He has to piss in his basement. >> peed in my basement.
>> [__] himself in the Walmart. How much do
you want to bet that if Gina Carano came out and said that she
was against Jeremy's deplatforming,
that he would become a sour simp for too. Like Okay, how much
does Gina love me out of out of out of 10?
I I find with people being anti woke grifters if you don't have
a kid. Like that's not even the problem here. The problem
is
calling other people out for not having kids. Like the thing
they literally don't have. That's the problem.
That's insane. He's like one of these return to tradition kids
who doesn't have kids. Never even Well, I guess he tried. Bro,
that's sad that he tried. That's actually you'd think he'd have
empathy there. That's actually really psycho
to try to have kids, not be able to have them, and then mock
other people for not having kids.
That's psychotic. >> Either a nine or an 11. Which one
is it? Gina and I could do a an excellent on screen uh Dude,
Britney let that really slide? The whole like it's kind of [__]
up to your wife. When you do the egg carton tweet at some woman
on the internet?
Like if if it's his wife with fertility issues, I guarantee you
any woman I know who's had fertility issues like at all,
it's it's incredibly hard for them to deal with, and he's tweeting
[__] like that at random women on the internet. You
think your wife doesn't follow your Twitter? You think she doesn't
see [__] like that? Dude, use your brain, man. >> uh
romance where like I'm the best friend. I'm like her best friend,
but I pine after her, and then she just keeps banging all these
other dudes. In his own fantasy, he's a And then we have a we
live happily ever after. Like I think we could do that. She could
just keep hooking up with fit dudes and then That's really telling.
That's actually That's he's sick.
I Who does that?
He's literally describing a lifestyle right now. >> dudes,
and then like they don't make her laugh, you know? They don't
they don't get her, and then there's me. Oh, you look tired.
You bang another dude tonight? Oh, sweet. And then like my heart's
breaking, you know? And all of this is what makes this so funny
that
Neil deGrasse Tyson about him cheating on his wife. You know,
he DM'd me while he was married asking if my friend was single.
Didn't Jesus say to not throw stones or something?
Wait, Jess, is that a different Jess? That's not the That's not
the the slasher Jess, right? That's a different
Cuz like
there's also Jess Southern who he made comments about. But if
he's asking about Jess Southern in 2021,
that's incredibly disturbing. I'm sorry. Yeah, that's I'm just
trying to rule out Jess Southern because if it's Jess Southern
he's asking about as like a 35-year-old man in 2021,
weird. He's actually a weirdo. >> asking if my friend was
single. Didn't Jesus say to not throw stones That's slasher Jess,
okay. Better Better less bad. >> she keeps herself in shape,
she takes care of herself. And what does he do? He continuously
humiliates her and walks around like a slob dressed in his poopy
palette. He should put some coffee brand coffee on those dark
circles of his. You know, so long as it's not 100% genetic. In
some cases it is, but in his case he just looks tired, which
is bad branding for his coffee. But anyway, now that you guys
have the context of the bull and how he didn't want that out
there, you can see why people would
want to talk about this, especially
Dude, it it I thought people were just making this up, but now
it feels like there's a couple different pointers.
There's a couple different things pointing at this that I'm
considering Jer is a Christian conservative building his entire
brand off of free speech. His lack of transparency is what led
to him having to message Josh Moon as a third party for a financial
audit, which we'll get into later. And he
That wasn't me, but Eddie over at Kick already added me. If I
want to, I could take their channel. I could take their channel.
I really don't want to, but I dude, there's a 0% chance Eddie
would kick the Dude, the Kino Casino is one of the most popular
programs on all of Kick. I honestly, if there's like an overall
Kick leaderboard on gifted subs, I do believe Kino Casino is
number one. Like if if there's anybody above Kino Casino, I would
be shocked.
Right? Am I crazy?
I feel like Kino Casino
Jess might be 27 Oh, is 27 now? Okay. All right, so 2021 22.
She just always looked young cuz she's small. Dude, Kino Casino's
sub totals are insane.
Like my sub totals beat most people on this platform unironically.
Like most streams I go to, I look at gifted subs, my sub totals
way higher than theirs. Right? But then I go to Kino Casino
and it's astronomical, man. There's no way they're kicking those
guys off the platform. Those guys are
And it's like maybe it might be the best original programming
Kick has.
I say that as somebody who competes like directly in their niche.
Like they might be the most entertaining show on Kick.
And it's like a Kick grown stream as well. Like I feel like I
feel like for as long as they've been Well, as long as I've been
aware of the show they've been on Kick. >> as a massive
melty threatening to go Karen mode at the Kick CEO to try to
get the Kino Casino deplatformed on there as well to specifically
target their livelihood. And how reasonable he's being to make
it so that they cannot
The whole time he's like guy he's like, I I really don't want
to do this, but they're forcing me to. I really don't want to
do this, but they're making me do it. I really don't want to
do this, but I basically have to. They're going after my family,
man. They're going after my family.
Bro, shut up. >> him or the details about his life that
he has elected to overshare. He even says, I'm not Mundane Matt,
my viewers 100% support this. Translation, I can get away with
it. >> Please tell me you are not flagging videos already.
Though Jeremy consistently has not taken accountability for it,
he does directly admit he threatened them after the fact about
taking down their channel. He also doubled down and refused to
apologize to them directly, which further encouraged his audience
to help try to get the Kino Casino deplatformed and subsequently
causing a mass flagging campaign where now every local is trying
to take free speech away and deplatform their critics because
Jeremy set the precedent that it's okay to do so.
Oh, let's not go after Jeremy too quickly and give him that much
credit. Ethan Klein's been doing this for a while, okay? Ethan
Klein's been a whiny
for a while now. All right? So, let's not pretend that The Quartering
set the set the standard here. There's another litigious whiny
dude there with no spine who's just mad at people doing the same
thing he's done for a long time, okay? And his name is Ethan
Klein.
Let's not Let's not give The Quartering too much credit. Oh,
he flagged me. Don't flag me. Flag the Kino Casino.
Uh Ethan Klein has falsely DMCA'd strike multiple people, multiple
channels.
Well, I should say multiple channels I mean like multiple different
false
Okay? I'm I'm saying he's also using the law to go after his
critics, okay?
So, maybe not maybe not mass flagging campaigns. Although I do
feel like he's probably tried
I feel like he's probably tried. I mean, what is the Twitch antisemitism
campaign and Ethan's participation in it if not a mass deplatforming
campaign?
Oh, yeah. Easy. Wait, I almost forgot. No, he did that, too.
He actually advocated flagging and advocated going after these
people as well. He's an active deplatformer as well. Oh, I forgot
about that. Quartering gets to start a mass flagging campaign
all while he gets to cry about how he's the one that's actually
under attack.
No evidence of that, of course. So, no, this isn't only drama
and gossip. This has to deal with a more serious topic of free
speech and being able to tell jokes about someone without them
crying harassment. And after the Kino Casino was suspended from
YouTube, Jeremy knows this because he covers the news entertainment.
This was the number one thing trending on entertainment on X.
And he proceeds to post his birthday card that is casino themed.
Oh, also.
Thank you to Dickers for the raid 9 minutes ago. I missed that.
Thank you very much, Dickers. I appreciate it. Even if it was
legitimate, you would think, "Hmm, if I don't want people to
think that I did it, maybe don't post it right when they Oh,
yeah. Like honestly, you were stupid to even say anything about
it to anyone. Like the idea that you might flag them is moronic,
but had a delicious steak dinner and maybe the most epic card
from The Quartering yet. Oh boy, from Mr. The Quartering yet.
>> his birthday card that is casino themed. Even if it
was legitimate, you would think, "Hmm, if I don't want people
to think that I did it, maybe don't post it right when banned
and it's trending on Twitter. In a weak moment, he did threaten
to report them, but he totally didn't do it even though he literally
leaked an email showing that he REPORTED A CHANNEL. >> QUARTERING
CAUGHT FLAGGING [screaming] IN 4K.
I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT IT wasn't our $10,000 a month because
it wasn't our channel, and we weren't getting the money from
it. It was our editor Flaked who has a newborn [__]
baby at home and a wife to [__] take care of who
had his six-figure year income taken away. Just a bummer people
are mad at me for no reason. FOR NO >> REASON! He pokes
the bear several other times and I wonder if they were going
to take care of their editor in the meantime. I feel like they've
got the money, but it's also like not my place to step in and
say they should take care of their editor. You'd hope they do
that if they can. >> of who had his six-figure year income
taken away. Just a bummer people are mad at me for no reason.
FOR NO REASON! HE POKES THE BEAR SEVERAL other times as well,
and he flexes his Rumble contract that quote allows him to do
this as he said to Josh Moon. He's able to do it through Rumble's
money. And the owner seems to be fine with it. >> Send
a strong message from me that you need to get your creators in
line. You need to send a strong message that you're not going
to support people deplatforming critics because that is a slippery
slope, one that I don't think DC really wants to travel down.
You're going to lose a lot of your strongest supporters. And
I highly highly recommend thinking about fixing this. >> Well,
you know what? Our representative's going to get you deplatformed
so that you can go on our platform.
It's so weird how you're saying he's not taking sides. And cry
Unfortunately, I don't think that's an incoherent position from
the the Rumble
That it's like, "Actually, even if this were happening, technically
that is also speech and while we don't support it, we're not
going to we're not never going to take him down for Rumble from
Rumble for that."
I think that's a fairly consistent position, no? As dumb as it
may seem. >> Jeremy here is the one doing this when he's
built his entire platform on free speech and making jokes at
other people's expenses, including their spouses. Your wife has
a son now or a daughter, I'm told. Good for
um her and the father and stuff like that. And dwelling on other
people is a recipe for continued failure, Matt. Focus on yourself.
Focus on your wife's child. Wait. Oh, no.
So, he doesn't even have grounds
to get out of this through like the family card, right? He totally
called this Matt Jarbo guy implied that it wasn't his kid. He's
done the exact same things to other content creators. He's just
mad it's happening to him now. Total cry bully
Focus on making things better off the
>> And building his whole career on criticizing people
and pointing and laughing at them when they say it's harassment.
But he's not allowed to be criticized or joked about. Even comedians
can't post their content without getting struck down. It's it's
getting scary. >> And in my opinion, another tell that
The Quartering is not for free speech is that he steals content.
If you go on his shorts page, there are endless videos, just
video after video of him doing a 5-second intro of saying, "Look
at this crazy clip." And then it just cuts to the clip and it's
like 3 minutes long.
Wait, The Quartering is doing Wait, who wants to go to The Quartering
[__]
To get the Sniperwolf
experience. Who's doing that? I kind of maybe get how you would
want it for your okay with Sniperwolf doing it. Like I get simps
on the internet being for I think she was an attractive woman,
right? I don't know. I Once I heard about the hair thing, the
never showering thing, I was like, "Ugh." But, you know, before
that, I kind of get how an attractive woman could do it and people
would simp for that. How does How does The Quartering getting
away with it?
>> What do you think?
No transformative content, no edits or Brother, that's cra- That's
I This is one of those videos where I'm like, "Oh, I didn't I
didn't hate this person anywhere near enough." or anything. Not
even a conclusion at the end. And he does this because he has
nothing to add. >> If you don't laugh at this, go see a
>> He just uploads his slop like his short slop to feed
the algorithm and it's the only thing inflating his channel's
numbers outside of him buying a bunch of
>> I've got to do a bunch of uh low-effort
uh short slop that everyone's really mad about. I've got to do
that even though everyone does it and, you know, instead of complaining
about it, you could just do it yourself. >> As a
and  free
See the race to the bottom behavior? I hate this. I hate this
so much. Yeah, I'm doing something bad, but why don't you do
it, too? How about cuz I'm not a
How about I don't want to be a degenerate. I feel like I could
do some things. If this doesn't work without me being a degenerate,
I don't want to do And then basically you run that iteration
a thousand times, you get to modern day
with whatever we're all doing now. It's so speech advocate, he
does not understand
why s- You don't If you don't like gambling, why don't you just
take a gambling contract? No. >> stealing content, rendering
their content and speech Which I think he also Is he not going
to do that? Did he do a gambling stream yet? I feel like he tried
to get on Kick.
useless, taking money and views away from them potentially. He
does not understand why this is bad. But he's free to try to
take down the Kino Casino for ban evading, for breaking the rules.
But he can break the rules and you're just jealous. Jeremy has
a history of repeated blackout streams. He seems to have a very
bad alcohol problem. And one of these streams that's very well
known is the in his basement stream. My wife went out for pizza
without me. I've seen this one before. This is one of the worst
ones I've seen. So, I'm going to win this Oh, he streamed Crimson
Desert on Kick. So, he does have a chance. >> round and
then I'm going to pee.
If I don't win this round, I'm going to pee in my own basement.
I'm not taking a pause to pee. Oh, I'm almost about to pee my
pants. I got to pee SO BAD. GET UP! [screaming]
NO! I JUST PEED in my basement. If you want to watch a streamer
that wants to pee in the potty, go watch someone else. Have I
done the floor yet while my wife is out of the bowl? You're right.
No, not yet.
I Why read the comment?
You literally don't have to Nobody's making you read the comment,
man. Nobody's making you read that comment. You do not have to
read that comment. >> were critical of him, including the
Kino Casino. He just constantly has dead air and he's a bad entertainer.
K. How? One.
Three. It's like five so far. >> Four. Six.
Seven.
I get it. I get this this would piss me off, too. I do get it
cuz I try even when I'm like I try to make sure that I've got
something going on most of the time. I feel very awkward if I
leave dead air in the stream. That's just me cuz it's like, "Dude,
that's what people are here for." The people are here to hear
something, they're here for an effort. And so, it just feels
like it's the minimum is just to make the effort most of the
time, right? Sometimes I'll be like quiet a little bit quiet,
be
And but for me, this is the way it is. I could maybe see getting
away with it if I had a camera on, but I don't have a camera
on even. So, I can't do like expressions or use silence to like
play around beyond outside of very obvious situations. So, for
me, I'm just like, "No, I can't I can't do that." Eight. That
doesn't count.
They don't call him Dead Air Jar for nothing. [laughter] Calling
what The Quartering makes content is generous because a lot of
it is just filler. Another example of his filler content is him
over explaining his technical issues that he seems to have like
every show. close OBS so they just stay on and overheat. They're
constantly giving me problems like this. Oh, yeah. >> I'm
like
I'm past the Amazon Why Why say the story? >> And if it's
not one of those two things, it'll be him asking how every What's
everyone got going on this weekend?
Would you like some content with your filler, sir? What are you
guys going up to uh What are you guys up to this weekend? He
loves to hide the evidence, constantly tweeting drunk and then
deleting the tweets all while begging his fans to support him
and pay for his lifestyle. So, let's get into the finance and
grifting segment. You'll find that Jeremy oscillates between
two polarities and this is just one example of it. One second
it's, "Guys, I'm very successful. I don't need to go on Caleb
Hammer's show." Which by the way, was one of the components that
started all of this for him having his melty. Uh the Kino Casino
asked to audit his finances because of this constant confliction
of saying he's rich, but he's poor. And they wanted a third party
like Caleb Hammer to go over his finances. And then he agreed
and backed out. And The Quartering will even joke about firing
his staff and it's not really a joke because he actually did
do it and says that he's poor, he can't afford his assistant,
he fired Luke Rudkowski. And that's another thing they made fun
of him for was his constant e-begging, his constant crowdfunding
even though he claims to be a multi-millionaire.
Jeremy loves to guilt his audience. He'll say things like, "I
never go on vacation."
A night that might actually lead to me taking a day off work.
I haven't taken a day off work in 3 years, but if I go on Nick's
stream later, I can generate another thousand sales on Coffee
Brand Coffee,
I might actually take tomorrow off. If my channel makes it through
this
it'll be a huge miracle. He's begged for his audience to bail
him out for overspending on coffee, which is a repeated theme
that he overspends money, by the way. I shipped way too many
Mother's Day gift boxes to Amazon. If I don't move through at
least half of what I sent there, Coffee Brand Coffee's going
out of business. That's how bad it is. But now I've marked it
down 10. I may have to mark it down, you know, more
Bro, this guy is so wide.
It's actually Like from just his face, you get the sense that
he's husky, but you wouldn't get like this frame. You These are
like the sweaters or shirts you would buy if you just gained
like massive amounts of weight and planned to gain more, basically.
Like, "I'm not changing [__] and I'm going to grow
into these sweaters. I'm going to grow into these shirts, all
right? I'm not changing a thing. I know I'm getting fat and I'm
going to get fatter, actually. I'm buying shirts that are two
sizes too >> Hawksbill Coffee is in huge trouble.
I'm going from a medium to a large? Nah. Going from a medium
to a double XL cuz I need to grow into it. >> level event.
I'm not like this isn't a shill, this isn't a gift a grift. I'm
asking for a bit of a bailout. Meanwhile, he can somehow afford
a saltwater fish tank.
That's insane.
Oh my god, I Dude, I've had
saltwater aquariums before. And the saltwater aquarium I had
was like 10 gallons, okay?
And that was expensive as [__] That was so [__]
expensive.
This tank has to be
20 grand to get to that point without stocking it. 20 grand at
least, I think. Maybe hold on, American. Maybe 12. Maybe 12 grand.
And then to stock it after that?
I feel like you're getting you're you got to be doing like 8
to 12. And then to put corals in there, it's going to go way
higher. Way way way higher. Dude, the the like just to set up
the filtration and all this stuff, it would be very expensive.
Yeah. Assuming he didn't custom make all of it, which I mean,
it looks like the stand maybe is custom made. Plus paying someone
to clean the fishes poop, the fish janny. Jeremy loves his jannies
to clean up his mess. >> Pick up the broom and sweep it
up. 180 gallons minimum? No.
That is That is
400 gallons? Maybe more. That's like 3 ft.
It's at least 2 ft depth-wise. Like having this this significant
depth here, that might be 2 and 1/2 3 ft depth-wise,
And then that's going to be 6 ft maybe longer across. That's
got to be That's got to be 3 400 gallons. That's not too too
No no no no no no no. He's 6 ft tall and look at how long the
tank is. I don't think that Like I think if he were to lay down
on the ground, I think he would be the same length as the tank,
no? Like it would be longer even. It looks to me like it would
be longer than him if he just laid down. He's 6'4". It is kind
of a weird angle. I think he said before it's 500. Yeah,
Trust me, also, that's a very tall tank. It's like low to the
ground, it's very tall. water fish tank plus paying someone to
clean the fishes poop, the fish janny. Jeremy loves his >> Sorry,
I I like aquariums, so I you know, that's I spend a little bit
I'll spend a little bit of time on that. >> up his mess.
Pick up the broom and sweep it up. Getting banned. Watch watch
watch. He better not. He better not ban him. HE BETTER NOT. HE
GOT BANNED. HE ACTUALLY HE actually banned him for just asking
how was your weekend. Bro, he's going to lose so many people.
He can apparently afford a $10,000 [laughter] RC race car track.
How much? Well, it was about $10,000 to do this. If you do it
yourself, probably it's going to be 4 to 5,000 dollars. If you're
not a lazy fat smelly bum like me, that shipping container was
like five or six grand. >> Contractor installs such as
solar vents and lighting. And inside,
uh I've run power. I'm not going to include that. That's like
a luxury. And Hawk's pooping on my track. Thanks, bud. New garage,
gym, car lift, car wash, studio sets, and an RV. What's the status
of the garage gym? We have all the permitting done. I want to
have a car wash in there. Like every man would love to have a
car wash in their garage, right? But then he'll turn around and
critic- Bro, how? This is actually more shameless than I thought
it would be. Holy [__]
He's got so many expensive things. Dude, like I don't I don't
do anything like that. I couldn't imagine doing all the begging
and then also building all that crazy [__] for yourself.
>> criticize other people for taking money and overspending
it. People stealing my money and then and then um living better
than I do. I think that these ghetto could come through with
a brand new iPhone and have a $0 copay on like $4,000 with the
medication that they were just selling anyway. Just because I
I can pay my bills now doesn't mean I think, you know, people
should be buying name brand
and all this other stuff when they're when [snorts] I'm paying
for it. Except his fans are the ones paying for it. He begs them,
guilts them, say he's going to go out of business, turn around,
buy a bunch of luxury goods by his own description, and then
just keep asking for more. It's crazy that in his own mind he
thinks he treats his audience well by like spamming them with
ads on ads, having them pay more money to get discounts on things.
So like spending money to have to spend more money. And then
the content that he charges them for is just the same content
that he already had repackaged.
It's just grift after grift after grift. And it gets to the point
where his own fans are tired of his coffee shills. They're say-
What's going on with member videos? Saying to not even buy coffee
anymore until morale improves. There are so many things that
he told his audience he would deliver on that I cannot sit here
and read them all. So you guys will have to pause to read. It's
just
How much time does he spend streaming, by the way? Does he stream
every day? Cuz my excuse for not fulfilling my
my Patreon benefits all the time is that I stream every day.
So if I'm not streaming every day, then I should be doing more
on the Patreon. But if I'm like streaming every [__]
then you know what? I can kind of justify it to myself. This
constant
But is Is Jeremy doing that? Is the Is the Quartering doing that?
>> crowdfunding and begging for money when he is a multimillionaire
and him continuously not delivering on what he says. Jeremy's
not above seemingly scamming charity for his grift, either. He
asked for his fans to pay for his trip with his co-host to Amfest,
which he already paid for, but he continuously asked for more
money to compensate for it. And he didn't need to go. It was
a huge waste of money. He didn't end up doing any interviews.
Just seemed like a waste of time to spend What was it? Like 12
to 16,000 dollars on this trip. His fans, after being disappointed
time time again, constantly sold things, having to pay to get
discounts on things. They actually funded the trip, but there
is a condition. One of the whales who funded him said, "You have
to donate the extra money to charity." Jeremy, what happened
to the Christmas cards or Toys for Tots dono from Amfest? Genuine
question, no troll. There was a donation made, and there wasn't
much left, to be honest. >> But then when he's asked about
his donation, he says that there wasn't much extra. We had one
person cover enough for the whole thing. Their only ask is that
everything we raised above and beyond that we would donate. There
definitely wasn't uh as much left
as I had hoped, but I made a separate donation at Toys for Tots
anyway. What I did do though was
purchase a bunch of cards to open on stream over the weekend.
I bought
a bunch of kids cards, you know. Oh
boy, everybody. I have about
$10,000 in product to open up. So just to be clear, the whale
No shot. There's no way
that he spent it all on magic cards for himself, right? >> All
of the expenses for the trip and he made $6,000
approximately prior to that. But he quote doesn't have that much
left over to donate to charity. It seems like those poor kids
got scammed out of their toys so that Jeremy could buy his. Those
Pokémon cards should be in the hands of some child. And if he
did donate, how much was it? Only a few hundred dollars?
Happens to the best of us. No. No, I don't think it does. >> he
did overspend and spent even more money for some reason cuz he
loves to waste money. He proceeded to spend like $10,000
on Pokémon cards, which he regularly loses money on because somehow
at a game where it doesn't require any skill, he still sucks
at it. And Jeremy can say, "No no no, that's not true." But if
it's not true, then why not get financially audited when you're
doing all these suspicious things, wasting your fans' money?
I mean, I do think at this point you should probably prove you
did the donation at least. Like give your tax receipt on that.
Cuz you definitely got a tax receipt if you If you donated money
to a charity, you definitely would have gotten a tax receipt
so you didn't get that taxed as income. >> Especially when
you live in a mansion and you're a multimillionaire.
And it seems like he's lying about his coffee grift as well.
He told his audience that he makes everything in house. It's
his machinery. Begged his audience for money for this. There's
a big difference between what I do and what most everyone else
does. I don't drop ship my coffee. We roast our own special blends.
We hand flavor our beans. We pack our orders. We ship our orders.
We handle our customer service. We are not a drop ship outlet.
We're a real coffee company. I need I
Okay. Need to I We had flavor Yeah, I don't know what that means.
I don't know what that means, but still. What was it? Stalin
is lost said, "I feel like that whale is a legit case for fraud."
I mean, I don't know if it's a case for fraud cuz I don't know
if you could like claw back donations. I also don't know what
the donation was through. Do we see if it was through Was it
through some like crowdfunding platform? I didn't pause for that.
If it was through like YouTube super chat, I guess there would
be a chunk of it taken away. No way. I love this book. I feel
like there's no way he actually read this book.
This is Coddling of the American Mind, Jonathan Haidt. I love
this book. I feel like I feel like insulted that he has this
book on his bookshelf.
Feel personally a personal insult from having that book on his
shelf. That's [__] up. try and reach out and give
get, you know, give you an understanding of why I could use some
help. What is the solution? Well, it's to buy about $80,000 in
equipment. And then it turns out that it's seemingly a white
label company that actually supports the SJW stuff that he says
he doesn't like and is woke. And for the past 3 years, I've proudly
kept my coffee brand coffee on remaining completely apolitical,
and that's literally why I called it that. And the overlap of
the staff, it's the same staff that's handling the generic coffee
that handles Jeremy's coffee. He just gives them t-shirts and
tells them to put it on so you can take the photo and say it's
his own staff. You may say, "Well, what's the big deal if it's
white label?" Well, the big deal is that he's lying to squeeze
more money out of his fans because he claims, "Well, we
Hold on. I'm going to go grab I'm going to have something to
eat here.
Did I just hear that he lied about the whole thing?
He just He just lied about the whole thing. It's just a different
coffee
>> the SJW stuff that he says he doesn't like and is woke.
And for the past 3 years, I've proudly kept my coffee brand coffee
on remaining completely apolitical,
and that's literally why I called it that. And the overlap of
the staff, it's the same staff that's handling the generic
This is my actual facility. >> He deleted the tweet. that
handles Jeremy's coffee. He just gives them t-shirts and tells
them to put it on so you can take the photo and say it's his
own staff. You may say, "Well, what's the big deal if it's white
label?" Well, the big deal is that he's lying to squeeze more
money out of his fans because he claims, "Well, we paid for the
machinery. I want you guys to pay for it. And this is our own
staff." And it's just this whole thing to try to get more money
out of his audience.
When he's talking about the machinery and stuff,
if he's not if that company is not fundraising through him somehow,
like maybe it is a friend's company and and he is like helping
them in some way,
dude, that's insane fraud. If he's just like out here fundraising
to get new machines, new equipment for his coffee company, that's
just going to his pocket, that'd be crazy. >> There's so
many inconsistencies. Like Player One Coffee, which is ran by
the CEO of Jeremy's sponsor Meta PCs, seems to be the one repackaging
the coffee when Jeremy says, "Oh, it's it's mine. I make it in-house."
And he admits that he doesn't roast his own coffee. So, it's
just this constant back and forth. Claims it's his staff, even
though it doesn't seem like it is. It just seems like he made
them put shirts on because it's the same staff if you cross-reference
the photos. And then he mentions the place that's actually making
the coffee while also pretending to not know what it is. Does
Mill Creek roast your coffee beans? Who's that?
Yeah, it's It's funny because the the woman who runs the company
is totally unaffected by it. She was like she was laughing about
it to me. Like I was seeing the emails come in and it was they
were hilarious.
Uh you did a little fulfillment work for a guy I don't like on
the internet. You as a woman, you shouldn't do like that's how
they read. See, I get my coffee from over a dozen providers.
It is his staff, it isn't his staff. He doesn't know the coffee
manufacturer, he does know it. They own the equipment, I don't
own the equipment. It's this constant
discrepancy. This is This is crazy.
Like this is actually too much.
How did he get away with this for so long? A lot of this stuff
is from very far back, isn't it?
It looked like I thought I saw 2020 on some of these things.
When did the coffee stuff come out? Why do I feel like I saw
2020 on one of these? Oh, these are where this guy's from a Facebook
post from 2020. Okay, maybe not. Who's that? >> ago did
the coffee stuff come out? Cuz I feel like the coffee stuff should
have been a huge story on its own. But was it just attached to
this? Like was it
Or has that been known for a while? >> funny because the
the woman who runs the company is totally unaffected by it. She
was coffee from over a dozen providers. It is his staff, it isn't
his staff. He doesn't know the coffee manufacturer, he does know
it. They own the equipment, I don't own the equipment. A lot
of people who run coffee companies
literally are just white labeling other people's coffee and selling
it in a way that they hope they can get people to buy it from
them and make a little bit of direct profit. That's like the
way it works. It's this constant
discrepancy. Successful business, but also can you guys pay for
my mistakes and bail me out? We're almost out of business. He
also admits that it's in Utah, which is where the actual manufacturer
was that he mentions in the video. These are my company, my employees,
located in Utah in the United States, all salaried. So, it's
like which is it? Well, in my opinion, I think it's pretty clear
that this is a white label thing and he's trying to cover it
up to squeeze more money out of his audience. And then people
who talk about it are getting flagged. And you know, The best
case scenario in my opinion for this is that he found some coffee
company somewhere close by. He like knows the owners.
And he's like help He's getting them to make his coffee, but
they also do their own local thing.
Right? I think that's like the maybe the
plausible defense or the most like, "Okay, you're not totally
defense." Anything beyond that, if it's like he sought out a
company that explicitly does white label coffee sales, he's No,
if it actually was what he said, I wouldn't complain about the
price. But it's crazy that it seems like he's just lying to his
fans about it being a generic coffee and then claiming everything
is his own when he just does what everyone else does, which is
fine, but be honest about it. >> big difference between
what I do and what most everyone else does. Which by the way,
you guys should check out Reed's Homemade Soap, artisan soap,
beef tallow soap, and they smell amazing. There's ones for guys,
too, like this one, the Ala Mao one.
Unfortunately, I'm taking Britney's entire video, and it was
a really good video, so I'm going to sit through the entire ad.
>> in the dark, and of course, I created the chemtrail
candle. I actually designed it, and Michelle made it with her
own hands in Oklahoma. So, if you want to actually support a
small business, you can go ahead and check out reedsoap.shop
and get yourself some beef tallow candles as well as soap. So,
Jeremy has left behind a long trail of smears, and it's really
starting to stink. If he was truly sorry about the platforming
starting a whole wave of people false flagging, >> he would
log off instead of just tweeting and deleting his tweets, and
he would go to rehab. But he doesn't, and instead he just keeps
victimizing himself. It just seems like he's powerless to all
of his addictions and not just alcohol. This is someone that
needs abstract thoughts explained to them like, "Imagine food,
but there's nobody to feed it to you." Genuinely, he might be
brain damaged from all that drinking. That might be why he can't
even point to the Middle East on the map despite him covering
the politics surrounding Iran. You know, the holding pattern
was. Mhm. Um so, if we go thing, isn't it? He's zooming in to
Southeast Asia. What is He's ZOOMING IN TO INDONESIA AND AUSTRALIA
FOR
>> I THINK HE THINKS THE water is the land. I'm not even
joking.
The Strait of Hormuz.
Is it It's not here. I got to zoom [laughter] out more. THAT'S
THE ATLANTIC OCEAN.
THAT'S THE ATLANTIC OCEAN. YOU'RE IN THE
Like Like you immediately pause. You go Africa. Okay, we're like
right here. Like it's so easy. It's so It's so easy. Africa?
Oh. Oh.
Oh, that's like Saudi Arabia. Okay, that's like the Strait of
Hormuz right there. Okay. Okay. Okay. >> YOU [__]
WHAT'S HE looking [laughter] for? What's the thing called? I
couldn't He's looking for Iran.
He doesn't He's not even Bunny, are you
Andy! ANDY HAD A BETTER IDEA. AT LEAST ANDY KNOWS WHERE THE MIDDLE
EAST IS. I really try to stay out of the the stuff. That's right.
Science stuff. I don't understand at all. And if you
>> like it could ruin your career.
This is so funny. This is what I talk about sometimes. People
who are really dumb are actually anti-Semitic
in a way that comes off as like philo-Semitic. Like they love
But they're actually just anti-Semitic and they think control
the world, but they're too dumb. They know they're too dumb to
talk about it. So, they're just like, "I never talk about it
cuz I'm like scared they're going to blow me up. I'm scared I'm
going to get paid one day. It's going to be the end for me."
That's That's literally what's happening here. America first,
America last. Whatever happens over in Israel,
you know, I I don't really care. >> He'll go back and forth
on anything, even with politics like he did with Jack Posobiec,
calling him out for his parties, but then wanting to have him
on the show. So, Jeremy Hambly started virtue signaling about
how much better he is than Jack Posobiec and how he doesn't engage
in the degeneracy at all of these conservative after-parties
and the horrible things that he's seen,
He says the reason
Dude. Dude.
He's the guy.
I'll never be able to find a tweet. I can't remember the guy's
name.
Do you remember the dude who basically got like checked by Ala?
That was like, "Wait, you had an orgy? Why didn't you tell me
about the orgy?"
And then everybody laughed at that guy. Basically, like like
he didn't get an invite. That's like Jeremy, okay?
Jeremy's the All these people having totally debaucherous All
cheating on their wives. Jeremy's trying desperately
desperately to any woman other than his wife, and nobody will
him. And now he's So, he's going to call out the degeneracy.
I watched three different conservative women, three different
totally fake conservative women
[__] Jack Posobiec in a room at the same time, and
they refused to touch me, and I will not allow it anymore. I
do not attend IRL Like Elon? Exactly like Elon. events very often
is because I what I saw from Jack Posobiec and his brother at
one of the few IRL events I ever attended. It shattered the entire
online persona I had come to respect him, his brother, and a
set cult woman. Now, he's referring here to Miss Klein of the
NXIVM cult, who was making the rounds in the right-wing circles
a number of years ago trying to rally defenders for the NXIVM
cult whose leader is currently serving 120 years in prison for
convicted
in human trafficking.
And Jack Posobiec was palling around with this woman and Jer
is calling it out. Okay, next tweet. Okay. There we go. He says,
"I watched Jack parade around a woman from a cult at the only
live event I was ever at. Maybe I'll tell that story." Now, mind
you, this was years and years ago. He says he took down Jack
Murphy and that was the far more difficult Jack to reveal the
truth about. Well, it turns out that Jeremy Hambly, despite what
he's saying here about Jack Posobiec, just a few months ago was
inviting Jack Posobiec on for an interview with him at Amfest.
He was begging Jack Posobiec for clout and to be associated with
him knowing what he knew about Jack Posobiec. And it's actually
going to get a lot worse after that.
Click theory to our actual account and click follow. Because
the reason it's really important you follow and you download
the app this coming up week because we have we are packed to
the gills with guests. We're going to have more and more guests
Which by the way was a super big lie. >> It was a lie.
All the guests that he promised [laughter] actually were never
interviewed. So, he scammed that aspect of the Amfest fundraisers.
Well, you can go to our YouTube clip channel. You can go through
the playlist. You can learn everything for yourselves. >> It's
all there. I think I sent Hannah Claire like a half dozen last
night. Um I know Myron wants to come on. Jack Posobiec um ourselves.
I think I sent Hannah Claire like a half dozen last night. Um
I know Myron wants to come on. Jack Posobiec um We're going to
have a After what he said about Jack Posobiec that he knew for
years, he still wanted to interact with Jack Posobiec and engage
with him. And I wonder why. Cuz he was mad about Jack not showing
up at Amfest. Exactly. The only reason he made these comments
about this cult is cuz he was upset that Jack stiffed him and
didn't show up at Amfest. But,
it gets worse. Let's go to the next
It gets a lot worse from for Jer because
How could it get worse? >> woman that he was upset that
Jack Posobiec was associating with at a conservative event, Jeremy
Hambly invited that same woman into his home. This was the number
two woman in the organization,
the NXIVM
Ghislaine Maxwell cult of that organization. You can learn all
about them in the HBO documentary The Vow. But, not only did
he invite this cult woman into his home, but he will call her
in this clip a good
I wonder why he wants us silenced. Folks, I wonder why. And by
the way, we had a more thorough version of this on Now, found
on the Gumroad, by the way. uh last week's uh clip channel. So,
you can find it there about the NXIVM
NXIVM cult and all that stuff. So, we had like a 3-hour show
about it. >> watching um a documentary or or a video out
that's out right now on the NXIVM
uh the NXIVM or whatever. And I know two of the people that were
in that. Really?
I I know people in the kidnapping sect. Cult? Why would you smile
while saying that? It should be like, "I know two."
Bring them on. One of them spent to my house. They've been to
your house?
They're One I didn't dabble in the cult, but I know all about
it from the inside. Oh. Oh. So, you masqueraded as a dabbler.
I respect that even more. >> I became good friends with
the number two lady after >> Good good friends with the
number two lady in the organization
who's been in his home. This is an organization that's women
that mol- children that branded women with irons that participated
in sleep deprivation, calorie deprivation,
all forms of human Okay, the number two in the cult though, like
did she was maybe she like the whistleblower or something? Maybe
she didn't I don't know. Is there some way that you could explain
this? Is there some way you could like make this make some sense
that Is there some sob story she has at least?
And Jeremy Hambly considers the number two woman in this organization,
basically a Ghislaine Maxwell type woman who would procure women
for the leader's desires, a good friend that he invites into
his home. I wonder why he wants us silenced. I wonder why he
wants our channels taken down. I wonder why he wants our livelihood
destroyed. It's because we showcase things like this in a humorous,
mocking way that is effective and it scares him and it makes
him upset and he cries. Jeez.